aujourd'hui à des séries pour tous les
goûts les courtes des longs des comiques
dramatiques story documentaire de
l'animation c'est quand même rare les
gens qui le disent
non moi je regarde aucune série aucune
0,11 euro rien tu viens d'où je viens de
pluton eu de banlieue parisienne
[ __ ] emmaüs veut ça mais maintenant je
veux rentrer chez moi bel esprit
bravo route à deux manières de regarder
des séries soit tu regardes un épisode
de temps en temps tu fait durer le
plaisir soit un des gros problèmes
d'addiction tu ramènes chine c'est trop
même puisque qua non par de breaking bad
la série tu connais pas va pas taper
nuit non mais attends maintenant il faut
que tu regardes tu vas tellement qui
fait c'est génial à regarder premier
épisode ce soir là je vous dirais bon
alors ça va tu peux regarder
j'ai tout regardé breaking bad mais
c'est pas possible ça fait plusieurs
dizaines d'heures de suite je regarde
plusieurs saisons en même temps la
nouvelle saison de 25 ans le seul que
c'est quoi ça sert à rien tu veux pas
voir souffrir nous dire combien de
saisons soutien regarde tout d'un coup
ce sont aussi le genre de gens qui quand
une nouvelle saison commence il préfère
attendre que tous les épisodes sont
sortis pour pouvoir tout regarder d'un
coup comme ça moi je ne peux pas faire
ça y'a trop de risque de spoil comment
font les gens là c'est bon tu peux
sortir ta tous les épisodes de gamme au
choix qui sont sortis enfin outre une
nouvelle saison qui est annoncé ouais
ferme
je viens de commencer une nouvelle série
surtout s'il ya plein de saison c'est
quand même des dizaines et des dizaines
d'heures devant ton écran c'est lourd de
conséquences soyez pas inconscient comme
les mecs qui peuvent te sortir
franchement tu devrais commencer la
série les sopranos ou the wire ou les
deux mais non tu peux pas dire ça c'est
comme si tu disais franchement tu
devrais apprendre le mandarin ou devenir
ingénieur en aéronautique ou non avant
il y avait quelques bonnes séries
passent à la télé tu savais où les
trouver maintenant quand tu sais pas
quoi regarder et que tu lances genre
netflix a trop de choix
hélas trop ça non tom cruise écoute ça
fait quarante minutes là pour chercher
un très franchement on aurait pu
regarder un épisode entier ben le
prochain truc vas-y on le regarde je
suis au près en ces bombes addition mais
oui bien sûr non non pas ça
[Musique]
sur les flics sont tu regardes les
épisodes d'une série à la fin ils te
démarre automatiquement l'épisode
suivant et au bout de quelques épisodes
il te balance un message pour être sûr
que tu t'es pas endormi été obligé de
valider ils te disent ils vouent
toujours en train de regarder votre
série est là quand tu appuies sur
continuer de regarder tu te sens tu te
sens un peu comme une merde mais pas ce
que je fais voilà encore un petit
épisode à mon avis doit dormir qui
regarderait huit épisodes d'affilée
personnes les gens sortent ils font du
sport ils vont voir des expositions il
peut s'y serait pas avaler comme une
merde à regarder des séries pendant des
heures ainsi si je rentre je continue à
regarder par oops
désolé bon visionnage peut-être que
j'aille me coucher je trouve un emploi
aussi alors je pense que netflix est le
service le plus partagé de la planète en
face mentières tout le monde veut
gratter le compte de tout le monde
personne ne veut payer d'abonnement la
grande question est qui va tout donner
son compte et le mot de passe de mon
contenu fixe est attribué
je je je m'attendais pas du tout
aussi déjà mais mes parents axe dans la
salle chez kuhn regard vers ce que
m'avoir donné une douceur et puis merci
vasseur de payer 13 euros 99 je suis un
peu ému m'attendais pas du tout j'ai
vécu un truc assez bizarre avec les
séries il a longtemps je regardais les
séries en version française en vf et
pour regarder la suite des nouvelles
saisons j'étais obligé de regarder en vo
et là ça fait très bizarre de voir les
personnages que tu connais avec une
autre voie pourtant cessé leurs vrais
voir mais ça ça fait bizarre c'est comme
si maintenant je parlais avec cette voie
là voilà je sais pas ce que ça vous fait
mais voilà c'est bizarre on est d'accord
d'ailleurs en parlant de bo quand un
épisode vient tout juste de j'arrête
avec ses doigts vous inquiétez pas ce qu
un nouvel épisode vient tout juste de
sortir à l'étranger en plein milieu de
la nuit chez nous une heure plus tard il
est déjà sous titrée en français ou les
sites illégaux
y'a des mecs qui traduisent comme ça
dans la foulée un peu mieux la nuit
c'est un peu nos héros du quotidien par
ce matin j'ai vu le dernier épisode de
walking dead est lui sorti dans la nuit
ouais mais j'ai trouvé que les sous
titres par contre là les fautes
d'orthographe non mais le mec il confond
les ter sérieusement je te jure il fait
ça dans la nuit à 4h du mat normale et
peut-être des fautes ouvrir un
bescherelle quoi moi les fautes ça me
sort de l'histoire enfin il fait ça de
son temps libre c'est sympa de sa part
de traduire et demi entre le pseudo
traduction d'un réseau de 28 nouvelles
vitaux alors l'épisode et écoute ait des
morts j'te dis ou pas
comme avant
alors les verbes du premier goût
aujourd'hui les séries elle te stresse
trop à tout moment et un personnage que
tu adores qui peut mourir
ils font ça tout le temps dans game of
thrones dans au king day dans joséphine
ange gardien
non pas dans le film mais comment font
les scénaristes pour se mettre d'accord
ils ont un pouvoir comme ça on va tous
tes tu es tu et scénariste est ce que
c'est un baratheon et non tous jouent à
kiev qui reste au ps que c'est un bâtard
non enfin si mais bon moi je me suis
trompé je l'aurais su si je reste en vie
[Musique]
cliquer juste ici pour ta bonne est allé
à puis tu peux le faire
you can do it